[Music]
it was the most devastating of attacks
the cold-blooded slaughter of 51 people
worshippers gunned down at two mosques
in new zealand as they prayed we
just started the prayer when i had to
you know i was pushing me down
somebody's killing me what's here
he's killing our brothers i'm saying go
down go down so he's an animal
animals nothing but animals
and abdul aziz were both at linwood
islamic center in christchurch
when the terrorists arrived and started
shooting
there was screaming yelling at him come
on here because i didn't want him to
come inside the mosque because we had a
lot of people between 80 200 people was
praying that day
and i wanted to focus on me
but unfortunately he come inside and
shot a lot of brothers and sisters
men women and children were murdered
indiscriminately then i chased him to
his car when he sat on his car because
we had a bit of distance and i just
throw that shotgun on his
side window and smash this side window
he just looked at me and he just gave me
a finger
killed all of you before arriving at
linwood
the gunman had already killed more than
40 people
at the city's al noor mosque guilty or
not guilty
yes guilty brenton tarrant has admitted
51
charges of murder 40 of attempted murder
and committing a terrorist act and he'll
be sentenced
this week people came to us here
and they gave us assurance and gave us
support
and i hope that his term in prison
is going to be so long through his life
so that he can taste it the same thing
as those people the children the widows
who tested also the
the pain
a crime of hate provoked an outpouring
of love
and unity but what was stolen
cannot be replaced i don't think not a
single day
i will not feel the
you know the
[Music]
the depth of the agony you know we went
through that day
not a single day the terrorists behind
new zealand's worst mass shooting
is expected to spend the rest of his
life in jail
siobhan robbins sky news